Willkommen an der Theresianischen Militärakademie
Wiener Neustadt. Mein Name ist Oberst Markus
Reisner, ich bin Leiter der Entwicklungs- und
Forschungsabteilung der Militärakademie und
heute werden wir uns in einem weiteren Video die
Fähigkeiten der russischen Bataillonstaktischen
Gruppe anhand eines Beispiels im Gelände ansehen.
Dazu noch einmal kurz die Gliederung so wie es im
ersten Video dargestellt worden ist.
Ich gehe nur ganz kurz darauf ein,
wir haben auf der einen Seite in Rot eingekreist
die sogenannten Kampfteile. Hier als wesentliche
Elemente eine Kompanie motorisierte
Infanterie, auf BTR-82A, 2 Kompanien
BMP-1 Kampfschützenpanzer und eine Kompanie T-72B3
Kampfpanzer. Zentral in der Mitte vor allem die
wesentlichen Anteile der Kampfunterstützung,
das sind vor allem die Rohr-Artillerie aber
auch die Mehrfach-Raketenwerfer, in diesem
Fall vor allem BM-21 und TOS-1 aber auch
zusätzliche Kräfte wie zum Beispiel Pioniere
oder Fliegerabwehr. Rechts davon die Elemente
der Führung, hier als wesentliches Element ein
Aufklärungszug und zusätzliche Drohnenaufklärung,
darunter zusätzliche Elemente der
elektronischen Einsatz- bzw. Kampfführung,
rechts davon die Einsatzunterstützung zur
Versorgung dieser Kräfte, die durchaus bei
einer Operation über eine höhere Entfernung
auch massiver ausfallen kann. Sehen wir uns
nun das Gelände an, das wir für dieses Beispiel
verwenden. Das Gelände, das wir gewählt haben,
ist sehr einfach. Wir haben hier eine Ortschaft,
die durchschnitten wird durch zwei Bewegungslinien
von Nord nach Süd und von West nach Ost. Parallel
dazu haben wir zur Bewegungslinie von Nord nach
Süd einen Fluss mit zwei Brücken, im südlichen
Bereich bewaldetes Gebiet und nordostwärts der
Ortschaft eine Geländekante. Der Kommandant der
Bataillonstaktischen Gruppe hat den Auftrag,
diese Ortschaft einzunehmen. Wir haben jetzt
eine Möglichkeit dargestellt, wie er das mit
seinen verfügbaren Kräften machen kann und
diese Gefechtsidee legen wir nun ins Gelände.
Das erste Element, das er einsetzt, ist seine
bodengestützte Aufklärung. Der Aufklärungszug
bezieht gedeckt durch den Wald am Waldrand
Stellung und klärt die Ortschaft auf und erkennt
hier einen in Stellung befindlichen feindlichen
Kampfpanzerzug. Als nächstes Element setzt er
seine Kampfpanzer-Kompanie ein. Diese bezieht
an der Geländekante Stellung mit dem Auftrag,
den nun folgenden Angriff zu unterstützen,
erkannten Feind niederzuhalten und zu bekämpfen.
Zusätzlich führt er bereits heran: Elemente
seiner Reserve. Dieses Reserve dient ihm in
weiterer Folge dazu, wo notwendig örtlich
Kräfte einzusetzen, zu verstärken oder bei
einer Krise im Gefecht zu handeln. In unserem Fall
ist es eine Kompanie motorisiert, also BTR-82A,
verstärkt durch einen Panzerabwehr-Lenkwaffenzug,
der diesem Element auch die Möglichkeit gibt,
gegen mechanisierte Kräfte wirksam zu werden. Zur
unmittelbaren Vorbereitung des Angriffs setzt er
nun seine Kampfunterstützung ein. Diese besteht
aus einer Batterie BM-21 Raketenwerfer im Norden,
dargestellt hinter der Geländekante, und einer
Batterie Rohr-Artillerie 2S9 oder 2S19. Diese
dienen dazu, die gegnerischen Kräfte in der
Ortschaft zu bekämpfen und die Voraussetzungen zu
schaffen für den weiteren Angriff. Dieser Angriff
wird durchgeführt durch zwei Grenadierkompanien,
links und rechts der Straße als Mittellinie
folgend, unterstützt durch die Kampfpanzer
und nach Vorbereitung durch das Feuer der
beiden Batterien BM-21 und Artillerie. Das
führt dazu, dass es bereits wesentliche
Ausfälle gibt. Die restlichen Kräfte:
Hier hat als zusätzliches Element noch seine
sogenannte Durchbruchs-Artillerie - das ist der
Raketenwerfer TOS-1, den er ebenfalls
einsetzt. Dieser verschießt auch von
relativ kurzer Entfernung von drei-
bis viertausend Meter thermobarische
Raketen mit einer verheerenden Wirkung und das
führt zu weiteren Ausfällen in der Ortschaft,
sodass dieser Kampfpanzerzug bereits wesentlich
verringert ist. Um sicherzugehen, dass der
Gegner nicht Elemente seiner Luftunterstützung
heranführt, wird die Fliegerabwehr etwas weiter
nach vor gezogen, die bereits seit Beginn
dafür sorgt, dass dieses Element hier, das
eigene Element der Bataillonstaktischen Gruppe,
sich unter dem Schutz dieser Kräfte befindet.
Als weiteres Element greifen dann diese beiden
Grenadierkompanien an und nehmen den westlichen
Rand. Die Ortschaft ist somit quasi im Besitz
dieser Bataillonstaktischen Gruppe. Nun geht
es vor allem darum, sich zu reorganisieren und
darauf zu achten, dass nicht zusätzliche Kräfte
des Gegners herangeführt werden, um zum Beispiel
einen Gegenangriff durchzuführen. Das Erste,
was er macht ist: Er nimmt seine Pionierkräfte
und lässt sie als bewegliche Sperrabteilung einen
Minenriegel beziehen am nördlichen Ortsausgang,
um zu verhindern, dass es zu einem flankierenden
Stoß des Gegners kommt, der möglicherweise die
eigenen Kräfte in der Ortschaft gefährden kann.
Zusätzlich zieht er Pionierkräfte heran, um die
etwas beschädigte Brücke wieder instandzusetzen
oder so zu forcieren, dass es möglich ist sie in
weiterer Folge auch nützen zu können. Dies gilt
natürlich unter Umständen für beide Brücken,
die sich in der Ortschaft befinden. Zusätzlich
führt er seine Drohnen-Aufklärung heran. Diese
hätte er bereits am Anfang einsetzen können,
er hat sich aber in diesem Fall dazu entschieden,
das erst am Schluss zu tun - vor allem, um sich
ein Lagebild in der Ortschaft zu machen und darauf
zu achten, dass nicht versprengte Kräfte noch
wirksam werden können oder möglicherweise Kräfte
aus der Tiefe herangeführt werden. Seine Kräfte
der elektronischen Kampfführung, die er auch
von Beginn an eingesetzt hat, führt er ebenfalls
näher heran, um für den Fall der Notwendigkeit
zusätzliche Stör-Elemente verfügbar zu haben,
um die gegnerische Kommunikationsstruktur
gezielt stören zu können. Nachdem diese
Elemente sich ja nun in der Ortschaft so
befunden haben, führt er seine Kräfte der
Einsatzunterstützung heran. Diese haben nun den
Auftrag, die Versorgung der Teile durchzuführen,
darunter zählt die eigene Verwundetenversorgung
und der Abschub zu dem nächsten Element der
Sanitätsversorgung. Der Kommandant der
Bataillonstaktischen Gruppe reorganisiert
sich nun und entweder hält das gewonnene Gelände
oder er setzt weiter an, in einer Art und Weise,
wie er es dann abhängig vom Gelände entscheidet.
Damit haben wir Ihnen kurz dargestellt:
die Fähigkeiten der Bataillonstaktischen Gruppe
in einer Optimalgliederung, wie wir sie auch
jetzt zurzeit in der Ukraine im Einsatz sehen,
und ich denke, es ist für jeden nachvollziehbar,
dass jede dieser einzelnen Fähigkeiten valide
in der Kampfführung eine entsprechende Rolle hat
und dazu auch benötigt werden. Ich sage danke fürs
Zuhören und auf Wiederschauen aus Wiener Neustadt.